‏If are here
quiet
and don't wait for someone else to make
quiet make
right next to you.
Well, he's got the idea here. ان شاء
الله
الحمد لله
7 10 years old
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]
اكبر
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم بسم
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط راط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
[Arabic recitation]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
والفجر
وليال عشر والشفع والوتر
والليل اذا يسر هل في ذلك قسم لذي حجر الم
تر كيف فعل ربك بعاد
ارم ذات العماد التي لم يخلق مثلها في
البلاد
وثمود الذين جابوا الصخر بالواد
وفرعون ذي الاوتاد
الذين طغوا في البلاد فاكثروا فيها الفساد
فصب عليهم ربك صوت عذاب
ان
ربك لبالمرصاد
فاما
الانسان
اذا ما ابتلاه ربه فاكرمه
ونعمه
فاكرمه ونعمه فيقول ربي
اكرما
واما اذا ما ابتلاه فقدر عليه رزقه فيقول
ربي
اهانا
كلا
بل لا تكرمون اليتيم
ولا تحا
ضون على طعام المسكين
وتاكلون التراث اكلا لما
وتحبون
المال
وتحبون المال حبا جما
كلا
اذا دكت الارض دكا
دكا
وجاء جاء
ربك والملك صفا صفا
وجيء
يومئذ
بجهنم
يتذكر
الانسان
وان له الذكرى
يقول يا ليتني قدمت
لحياتي
فيومئذ لا يعذب عذابه
احد ولا يوثق وثاقه
احد
يا
ايتها
النفس المطمئنه
ارجعي
الى ربك راضيه
مرضيه
فادخلي في عبادي
وادخلي جنتي
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال ضالين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
لا
اقسم بهذا البلد
وانت حل بهذا البلد
ووالد
وما ولد لقد خلقنا الانسان
في كبد
ايحسب ان لن يقدر عليه احد
يقول اهلكت مالا لبدا
ايحسب ان لم يره
احد
الم نجعل له عينين
ولسانا
وشفتين
وهديناه
النجدين
فلاقتحم
العقبه
وما
ادراكما
العقبه
فك رقبا
او اطعام
في يوم ذي مسغبا
يتيما ذا مقربه او مسكينا
ذا متربه
ثم كان من الذين امنوا وتواصوا بالصبر
وتواصوا بالمرحمه
اولئك
اصحاب الميمنه
والذين كفروا باياتنا
هم اصحاب المشامه
عليهم نار
مؤصده
الله
اكبر
سمي سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
اكبر بسم الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم خير
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
كده
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Arabic recitation]
والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك له
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد
وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين
اما
ت ان شاء الله
[Silence]
and
time
سهل بن سعد رضي الله عنه
صلى الله عليه مسان
انما الاعمال
بالخواتيم
من صحيح مسلم
سهل بن سعد propet صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
‏enthilty
could back time
‏time can back any
milk can go back into the after is
milked
done over
however
that doesn't mean that we can't change
how the past is judged
that's the point here
it's not necessarily
[Silence]
الله سبحانه وى
صلى الله عليه وسلم
انما الاعمال
بالخواتيم
الله سبحانه وتعالى
ولنجزينهم
احسن الذي كانوا يعملون
[Arabic recitation]
prop صلى الله عليه وسلم
at
lives
at the end of our
[Silence]
‏at
‏unable
don't look at my
you know is wearing socks
debration
انس مالك رضي الله
‏propب
عليه السلام
and prop صلى الله عليه وسلمر
صلى الله عليه
رcept
[Silence]
صلى الله عليه
‏are
more goble
person
to outle
until
that was
‏Now
it's important to understand that not
even one moment of this is to be was
even if things seem bleak as long as
there is air in your lungs and as long
as the angel of death is notysically
pulling your soul out of your
صلى الله عليه وسلم
احد
صلى الله عليه
‏was
الله سبحانه وتعالى
الادب المفرد
الامام البخاري
صلى الله عليه وسلم
اذا اقيمت ساعه
وفي يد احدكم
فسيله
فان استطاع ان يغرسها قبل
ان تقوم فليفعل فليغرسها
‏estn
is blown for the end of the
and you a palm shoot in your hand little
baby palm tree and you are able to stick
it in the ground before
the world ends then do it use that last
moment for
صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
‏Americans brush their teory.
Is it because we so hygienic and so
inent and soan? No, we have a culture of
brushing our teeth because of Colgate
because they wanted to sell us
toothpaste. ‏That's a true story.
And so a major campaign was started in
the 40s and 50s to brush your teeth.
People didn't do that before. What is
the driving force? The driving force is
so that people will admire the
freshness of your breath so that when
you go on a date, you'll be nice and
fresh.
This is not why we do the things we do.
صلى الله عليه وسلم
ان التسوك
او الاستياك
مطهر للفم مرضاه للرب
الله سبحانه وتالى
was
not minut
‏was all
now you wantous
youed
now youful
notameful
commfulyers
الله سبحانه وى
الله
الرحمن الرحيم الغفور الودفار
سبحانه وتعالى
‏And so
if
youat your last night on
you can turn around all
you can all around
there a ver inر
toare with you all of ush
this
in theinges سوره الفرقان
سوره المؤمن
الله سبحانه وتعالى
اولئك
يبدل الله سيئاتهم
حسنات
‏first all in me will makeut
willit you this is a fail at repentance
why do we fail because we are noting
our upon
‏We expect that I need to repent. I need
to take this journey on my own. That's
not how repentance works.
Repentance is only going to work if you
have on
if you open your heart and say, "Y
Allah, I'm to weak. I can't do this.
Please do this for me. Carry me down
this path." And then you try.
‏willing
on your
more important to learn the
learning
and this is why the first
نستعين
‏together
الله
وخلق
الله سبحانه وتالى take
الله سبحانه وتعالى
الله سبحانه وتالى
‏will
sin
for
have upon their future
will change them for them he will make
their bads good he will make their bad
habits good habits he willlace
الله
صحيح الامام مسلم عبد الله بن مسعود رضي
الله تعالى عنه
الله سبحانه وتعالى
‏ang
small sin and the major sin aside
meaning for him to be
judged for
and then the man will be brought
and he will be asked do you remember
doing this on this day yes do you
remember this when you did
‏Yes.
‏y
even got the meat and of what
so he's thinking is finished
الله سبحانه وتعالى
alles
sin
يا رب ان لي ذنوبا غير هذه
الله
صلى الله عليه وسلم
‏will
why would do this because
they can't change the
but they can change the past in the
sense of how it is judged remember
that's what we began with you go back in
the past and change it but you can
ان الله سبحانه وتعالى انا نحن نكتب ما
قدموا
واثارهم
الله سبحانه وتعالى
‏us
are
and if we are kind
of that I can't go back and change what
happen but if I could I would have done
this will compate for that
he will give you what you would have
done had you done based on who you
صلى الله عليه وسلم ان العبد يبعث على ما
كان عليه يوم القيامه
ان العبد يبعث يوم القيامه على ما مات
‏will
are
you have breath
and you breath to
and com from the of and of being that is
youracy
now this doesn't me well i can do what i
want ‏And then you know this is some
kind of cheat code it doesn't work like
that. You can'tat the system
because Allah doesn't look at outward
images. He looks at our deeds and our
intentions.
And a good way to make a minor sin into
a major sin
is to do that while quelling your
conscience.
‏that you will repent when this is over.
‏Remember the brother of what did they
start that you know how long was
father
at least at least 47 years
47 years that story infastenty
وتكون من بعده
قوما صالحين
قالوا تكاد تفتذ يوسف
حتى تكون حرضا او تكون من الهكين
50 years
when will this end that is how those ma
sin come about when you into
‏and gra
for us all for us all if man among
usight
that is innocent pleasise your
‏is here
is here
they have paradanteed
a place there
isilty and every right ‏to hold us to
account for what we have done and until
we realiz that we will not be forgiven
not until we just realiz it but embrace
it. ‏The only way the human being is
going to have a proper repentance is
when he embraces his imperfection
and believes with every fiber of his
beingilty
and we will end with this narration
after that
we will have the first part of our
very tight because we only got a few
chapters
‏compress
our than انء الله
صلاه and go into the
narهر
صلى الله عليه وسلم
اذنب عبد ذنبا
فقال اي ربي
قد اذنبت ذنبا فاغفر لي
فقال
ان لي عبدا
يعلم ان له ربا يغفر الذنب وياخذ بالذنب
قد غفرت لعبديش
صلى الله عليه وسلم
الله
[Silence]
‏And he is also capable of holding him
to account for that sin. I have forgiven
him.
You notice here what has to take place
in the heart.
You can't just be
well you know I'm not that bad. I'm not
as bad as that guy over there. So you
know why would why what does want with
me? I'm a good guy. I'm not that bad.
‏Yeah, sure. I do a little thing here
and there, but at the end of the day,
there's worse people out there. That's
not the kind of person that is meeting
Allah to expect forgiveness. That is an
arr entitled person
who has told himself that to many times
and has now started to delute himself.
Allah has every right to hold us to
account for every sin that we commit.
‏You know why
does anyone
have a right
to disob?
Does anyone have a valid excuse to
disobحه?
I disobeed
and I had a right to do so. Absolutely
not.
‏And every right to hold us to what we
have
those are
not to
differ
and so propائين
التوابون
‏sinistاء
وخير الخطين التوابون
‏and
are
what usart what the people of parad from
the people of hell
repentance
these over here repent constantly and
over here do not that's the differ
but there is not one of them that is
innocent not
‏So with that, isn't it nice that we're
all sitting here tonight? We got, you
know, these kids, they're a little bit
obnoxious, but we overlook it, right?
, weve got these kids running around.
We got everybody here. You can kind of
feel it in the air. You know what's
interesting about this?
We could do this every night.
‏believe
we don't upض
over you
what is one you
said
one goodit
one and
what
you
جمعه
and first
and there no reason why we do it us
being here right now proves we can do it
actually us being here right now it
actually proves that your sch
[Silence]
‏ubet
‏itle
ungency
and go 15 minut after
listen to props from
the
going to do that half an hour every
night that is for that is what I
contribute.
[Silence]
anday
soر
compers
[Silence]
صلى الله عليه وسلم
صلى الله عليه
[Silence]
الله
صلاه
سبحانك اللهم وبحمدك وتبارك اسمك وتعالى
جدك ولا اله الا غيرك وصلى الله وسلم على
[Arabic recitation]
سووا الصف سد الخلل
الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد
واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط راط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
والشمس وضحاها والقمر اذا تلاها والنهار
اذا
والليل اذا يغشاها والسماء
وما بناها والارض وما طحاها
ونفس
وما سواها فالهمها فجورها وتقواها
قد افلح من زكاها وقد خاب من دساها
كذبت ثمود بقواها
اذ بعث اشقاها
فقال لهم رسول الله ناقه الله وسقياها
فكذبوه فعقروها فدمدم عليهم ربهم
بذنبهم
فسواها
ولا يخاف عقباها
[Arabic recitation]
لمن حمده
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال الين
امين
والليل اذا يغشى والنهار اذا تجلى
وما خلق الذكر والانثى
ان سعيكم لشتى
فاما
من اعطى واتقى
وصدق بالحسنى
فسنيسره
لليسرى
واما
من بخل واستغنى وكذب بالحسنى
فسنيسره
للعسرى
وما يغني عنه ماله اذا تردى
ان علينا للهدى
وان لنا للاخره
والاولى
فانذرتكم
نارا تلظى لا يسها الا الاشقى الذي كذب
وتولى
وسيجنبها
الاتقى الذي يؤتي ماله يتزكى
وما لاحد عنده من نعمه
تجزى
الا ابتغاء
وجه ربه الاعلى ولسوف يرضى
[Arabic recitation]
لمن حمده
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام
عليكم ورحمه الله
السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
والضحى والليل
اذا سجى ما ودعك ربك وما قلاه
ولا الاخره خير لك من الاولى ولسوف يعطيك
ربك فترضى
الم يجدك يتيما
فاوى
ووجدك ضالا
فهدى
ووجدك عائلا
فاغنى
فاما
اليتيم فلا تقهر
واما
السائل
فلا تنهر
واما بنعمه ربك فحدث
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الم نشرح لك صدرك
ووضعنا عنك وزرك الذي انقض ظهرك
ورفعنا لك ذكرك
فان
مع العسر يسرا ان مع العسر يسرا
فاذا فرغت فانصب
والى الى ربك فارغب
[Arabic recitation]
لمن حمده
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضال
امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
والتين والزيتون وطور سينون وهذا البلد
الامين
لقد خلقنا الانسان في احسن تقويم
ثم رددناه اسفل فلسافلين
الا الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات فلهم اجر
غير ممنون
فما يكذبك بعد بالدين اليس الله باحكم
الحاكمين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
اقرا باسم ربك الذي خلق خلق الانسان من
علق
اقرا وربك الاكرم الذي علم بالقلم
علم الانسان ما لم يعلم
كلا ان الانسان
ليطغى
ان راه استغنى
ان الى ربك الرجعا
ارايت الذي ينهى عبدا اذا صلى
ارايت ان كان على الهدى او امر بالتقوى
ارايت ان كذب وتولى
الم يعلم بان الله يرى
كلا لئن لم ينته لنسفعا
بالناصيه
ناصيه خاطئه
كاذبه
ناصيه
كاذبه خاطئه
فليدع ناديه
سندع الزبانيه
كلا لا تطعه واسجد واقترب
الله اكبر
سبحانك
الله عز
وجل
تبارك الله
اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم انا انزلناه
في ليله القدر وما ادراكما ليله القدر
ليله القدر خير
من الف شهر
تنزل الملائكه
والروح فيها باذن ربهم
[Arabic recitation]
لمن حمده
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام
عليكم ورحمه الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
اوكي ان شاء
‏take minut and will
you
get drink pleas not
[Silence]
அலைக்கும்
‏If you do not recogniz them or you are
not missing them we going at the end of
the prayer insইশ the for this car
and the will go to the
[Silence]
there is one more thing we
‏wir
ان شاء
[Silence]
على مريضه
اوكي بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله
والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله اما بعد
قران
ان شاء الله
‏asn
place
up they willite what they have prepar
they take and will
you know present the other two
subsequent winners and the second level
and the third level will have
thoseitations
so let us goad
‏byn
first place for
brother مالك
مالك ما شاء الله where is come on up
[Arabic recitation]
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
غلبت الظوم في ادنى الارض وهم من بعد
غلبهم سيغلبون
في بضع سنين لله الامر من قبل ومن بعد
ويومئذ
يفرح المؤمنون
بنصر
ينصر من يشاء وهو العزيز الرحيم صدق الله
العظيم ما شاء الله تكبير
[Silence]
اوكي
سوره الروم ادم نمور ادم نمور ما شاء الله
الله اكبر
[Silence]
smiles jing
and
place for
ما شاء الله ياسر محمد
ياسر
ما شاء الله
[Silence]
ممر
سوره الروم سوره القمر
سوره القمر قصي ابو عواد
قصي ابو عواد
[Arabic recitation]
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
اقتربت الساعه وانشق
القمر وان يروا ايه يعرضوا ويق قولوا سحر
مستمر
وكذبوا واتبعوا
اهواءهم
وكل امر
مستقر
ولقد جاءهم
من الانباء
ما فيه
ما فيه مزدجر حكمه
بالغه
فماتون
النذر فتولى عنهم يوم يدعو الداع الى شيء
نكر
خشعا ابصارهم يخرجون من الاجداد كانهم
جراد منتشر
مهطعين الى الداع
يقول الكافرون هذا يوم عسر كذبت قبلهم قوم
نوح فكذبوا عبدنا
وقالوا مجنون وازدجر
فجع ربه
اني مغلوب فانتصر
ففتحنا
ابواب السماء
بماء
منهمر
وفجرنا الارض عيونا فالتقى
فالتقى الماء
على امر قد قدر وحملناه على ذات الواح
وجسر تجري باعيننا
جزاء
لمن كان كفر
[Arabic recitation]
ما شاء الله ما شاء الله اوكي زلمه الحاره
سوره القمر
حماد محمد حماد محمد
اخو ياسر
ما شاء الله
ما شاء الله ما شاء الله اوكي
سوره القمر عمر سحتوت عمر سحتوت ما شاء
الله
[Silence]
ما شاء الله
سان
سانر
دحت
داليا سحت ما شاء الله ماء الله
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم هل اتى على
الانسان حين من الدهر لم يكن شيئا مذكورا
انا خلقنا الانسان من نطفه امشاج
نبتليه فاجعلناه سميعا بصيرا
انا هديناه السبيل اما شاكرا واما كفورا
انا
اعتدنا للكافرين سلاسل واخلا وسعيرا
ان الابرار يشربون من كاس كان مزاجها
كافورا
عينا يشرب بها عباد الله يفجرونها
تفجيرا
يوفون بالنذر ويخافون يوم كان شره مستطيرا
ويطعمون الطعام على حبه مسكينا ويتيما
واسيرا
انما ندعمكم لوجه الله لا نريد منكم جزاء
ولا شكورا
انا نخاف من ربنا يوما عبوسا قمطريرا
[Arabic recitation]
سهان
place
[Silence]
اوكي
ء الله
الانسان خليل
خليل
ما شاء
ما شاء الله
الله اكبر الحمد لله
[Arabic recitation]
মাশাল্লাহ
জাস্ট টেকনোট হিজিং সাথিং
ও মাশাল্লাহ
الله
تস
[Silence]
ப
இஹரி
‏a
wonderful wonderful job
with all
‏here point
and leaders and
তাকব
was
এন্ডফ
হাফেate
[Silence]
‏ate
than to and man here in form of b
would you pleas come
[Arabic recitation]
‏Come on so you
طيب ما شاء الله ما شاء الله جزاك
হাফেজ আসম
কোরন
[Silence]
‏that
is very
aw actually want to say awome to haveம்
with usall
الله اكبر the best of
ما شاء الله
كلمه
بسم الله بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد
لله رب العالمين والصلاه والسلام على اشرف
الابي الانبياء والمرسلين سيدنا محمد وعلى
اله وصحبه اجمعين سبحانك لا علم لنا الا
ما علمتنا انك انت العليم الحكيم اللهم
علمنا ما ينفعنا وانفعنا بما علمتنا وزدنا
علما وفقها ورشدا اللهم امين وما بكم من
نعمه فمن الله وما بكم من نعمه فمن الله
عز وجل
يعني
امام علي
امانه
سبحانه وتعالى
مقص احمد جابر
مقصر سبحان الله
سبحانه وتعالى اللهم لا تؤخذني بما يقولون
واجعلني خيرا مما ما يظنون واغفر لما
يعلمون والله سبحانه وتعالى
وجعلني خيرا مما يظنون الله سبحانه وتعالى
ما يعلمون اللهم الله سبحانه وتعالى الله
سبحانه وتعالى
سبحانه وتالى
صحاب
رضي الله عنهم
صلى الله عليه وسلم
وتواصوا بالحق وتواصوا بالصبر
صحابه
كفاره المجلس سبحانك اللهم بحمدك نشهد ان
لا اله الا انت نستغفرك ونتوب اليك
سوره العصر والعصر ان الانسان لفي خسر الا
الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات وتواصوا
بالحق وتواصوا بالصبر
نتواصى
ان شاء اللهر
الحمد للهر
الله سبحانه وتعالى
يتلو عليهم اياته ويزكيهم ويعلمهم الكتاب
والحكمه
تزكيه
الله سبحانه وتالى
‏usah
bless allen
listeningر
ofان
ان الذين يتلون كتاب الله واقاموا الصلاه
وانفقوا مما رزقناهم سرا وعلانيه
يرجون تجاره لن تبلون كتاب الله
يتلحانه
ان الذين اتيناهم الكتاب يتلونه حق تلاوته
اولئك يؤمنون به الله سبحانه وتعال
الله سبحانه وتالى
الله
ill
to and
of me appointment writes prescription
ان شاء الله
سبحانه وتالى
[Silence]
تكيه
الله سبحانه وتعالى
ويزكيهروا
‏I need to be alwaysind myself and
others and I need
community each other with this right. So
كتاب الله always remember that you have
to apply it in your life.
[Silence]
علير
الله سبحانه وتعالى
الله سبحانه وتعالى قران لقد انزلنا اليكم
كتابا فيه ذكركم افلا تعقلون
فيهذكركم
فيه رفعت
فيه ذكركم اي فيه احوالكم
[Silence]
اللهمام
عليف
عليه السلام
الله سبحانه وتعالى
سبحانه وتعالى
ان الله والله غالب على امرهون
[Silence]
علير
عائشه رضي الله عنها
صلى الله عليه وسلم كان خلقه القران كان
قرانا يمشي على الارض
[Silence]
الدين تمشي على الارضوره
النساء تمشي على الارض
شراء الله سبحانه وتعالى
الله سبحانه وتعالى
الحمد لله سبحانك اللهم وبحمدك نشهد ان لا
اله الا انت نستغفرك ونتوب اليك وما بكم
من نعمه فمن اللهم اغفر لي ما يقولون
واجعلني خيرا مما يظنون واغفر لي ما لا
يعلمون والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
جزاك الله خير
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
يخاري داري
داري عاصم
رضان
ماء
‏more
of here
anything
‏are
when they cover so I want to say
thank you very much I know there was you
know this micr is very addictive if you
sit here you want to talk forever but my
intention is to thank both of them and
to say that what is been teaching us the
last few days that what we have learned
look at this crow everybody is
‏any
time
will
come here and
الله
يخ علي
جزاك الله خيرا شيخنا
ان شاء
ان شاء الله
جزاكم الله خيرا
ان شاء الله جزاكم الله
السلام
[Arabic recitation]
অমথ
শেখ মাম
আফজ
দারি এ হাফেজ
আসমস
কশ মসজিদ
হপশ
মসজিদ
ইলাম
আ
এ
মজ
আহামদুল্লাহ
commment comm
before
you
ofஹ
‏pr
and want make much strer
in the so pr you would you br and
sister to benit of that if you are not
able to use any other prram that we
offer so prram he is here in person he
can help us to bring the youth back to
the to the to the place we are able to
learn ‏and there is also any time off
hours will be posting so he is avilable
so this is a tremendous blessing that he
is among us he is comm heing
time and hopefully we can all
benit from him and make this community
much
جزاكم الله خلام
ان شاء الله
ان الله
just finish up the
two and
‏have
that
to the gym got some got some cakes got
you
invit everyone is welc than you
love بارك الله فيكم جزاكم الله خيرا
اوكي
استووا اعتدلوا
‏Stand shoulder to shoulder close all of
the gaps. Make sure that our rows are as
straight and coherent as possible. That
is part of the prayer and part of what
we reward.
Alhamdulillah.
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال الين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
لم يكن الذين كفروا من اهل الكتاب
والمشركين
منفكين
حتى تاتيهم البينه
رسول من الله يتلو صحفا مطهره
فيها كتب
قيمه
وما تفرق الذين اوتوا الكتاب الا من بعد
ما جاءتهم
البينه
وما امروا الا ليعبدوا الله مخلصين له
الدين حنفاء
ويقيم الصلاه ويؤتوا الزكاه وذلك دين
القيمه
ان الذين كفروا من اهل الكتاب والمشركين
في نار جهنم خالدين فيها
خالدين فيها اولئك
هم شر البريه
ان الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات اولئك
اولئك
هم خير البريه
جزاؤهم
عند ربهم
جنات
عدن تجري من تحتها الانهار
خالدين فيها
ابدا
رضي الله عنهم ورضوا عنه ذلك لمن خشي ربه
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
اذا زلزلت الارض زلزالها
واخرجت الارض اثقالها
وقال الانسان
ما لها يومئذ
تحدث حدث اخبارها
بان ربك اوحى لها
يومئذ
يصدر الناس اشتاتا
يصدر الناس اشتاتا ليروا اعمالهم
فمن يعمل مثقال ذره خيرا
يره ومن يعمل مثقال قال ذره
شرا
يره
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
والعاديات
ضبحا
فالموريات قدحا
صبحا
فاثرن به نقعا
فوسطن به جمعا
ان الانسان
لربه لكنود
وانه
على ذلك لشهيد
لحب الخير لشديد
افلا يعلم اذا بعثر ما في القبور
وحصل ما في الصدور
ان ربهم
بهم يومئذ لخبير
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
القارعه ما القارعه
وما
ادراكما القارعه
يوم يكون الناس كالفراش
المبثوث
وتكون الجبال كالعهن المنفوش
فاما من ثقلت موازينه
فهو في عيشه راضيه
واما من خفت موازينه
فامه
هاويه
وما
ادراكما
هي نار حاميه
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الهاكم التكاثر
حتى زرتم المقابر
كلا سوف تعلمون
ثم كلا سوف تعلمون
كلا لو تعلمون علم اليقين
لترون
الجحيم
ثم لترونها
عين اليقين
ثم لتسالن
يومئذ عن النعيم
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
السلام
عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
والعصر
ان
الانسان
لفي خسر الا الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات
وتواصوا بالحق وتواصوا
بالصبر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
ويل لكل همزه لمزاه
الذي جمع مالا
وعددا
يحسب ان ماله
اخلده
كلا ليبذن
في الحطمه
وما
ادراكما الحطمه
نار الله الموقدا
التي تطلع على الافئده
انها
عليهم
مؤصدا
في عمد
ممددا
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الم تر كيف فعل ربك باصحاب الفيل
الم يجعل كيدهم في تضليل
وارسل عليهم طيرا ابابيل
ترميهم
بحجاره
من سجيل
فجعلهم كعصف
ماكول
[Arabic recitation]
لايلاف قريش
ايلافهم رحله الشتاء
والصيف
فليعبدوا رب هذا البيت
الذي اطعمهم
من جوع
اطعمهم
وامنهم
من خوف
الله
[Arabic recitation]
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر سبحان الله
سبحان الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر سبحان رب
سبحان
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن
الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
ارايت الذي يكذب بالدين
فذلك الذي يدع اليتيم
ولا يحض على طعام المسكين
فويل للمصلين
الذين هم عن صلاتهم ساهون
الذين هم يراءون
ويمنعون
الماعون
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
انا
اعطيناك
الكوثر
فصل لربك وانحر
ان شانئك
هو الابتر
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
قل يا
ايها الكافرون
لا
اعبد ما تعبدون
ولا
انتم عابدون ما
اعبد ولا
انا عابد
ما عبدتم
ولا
انتم عابدون ما
اعبد
لكم دينكم ولي دين
الله
[Arabic recitation]
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
اكبر
من الشيطان الرجيم بسم الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن
الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
اذا جاء
نصر الله والفتح
ورايت الناس يدخلون في دين الله افواجا
فسبح بحمد ربك واستغفر ره انه
كان توابا
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
[Arabic recitation]
اكبر
الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعم انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
تبت يدا
ابي لهب
وتب
ما
اغنى عنه ماله وما كسب سيصلى نارا
ذات لهب وامراته
حماله
الحطب
في جيدها حبل من مسد
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر سبحان الله سبحان الله سبحان
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه رحمه الله
make صلاه now ان شاء الله
in
دعاء ختم القران
الله
اكبر
اللهم بيني وبين خطايا كما بعد بينشر
مغرب الله خطايا
ونبيض من التنسي
من خطاياي بالماء والثلج والبرد اعوذ
بالله السميع العليم من الشيطان الرجيم
همسه ونفخه ونفذيه
بسم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
قل هو الله احد الله الصمد
لم يلد ولم يولد
ولم يكن له كفوا احد بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم
قل اعوذ برب الفلق
من شر ما خلق ومن شر غاسق اذا وقب ومن شر
النفاث ثات في العقد
ومن شر حاسد اذا حسد بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم
قل اعوذ برب
الناس
ملك الناس اله
من شر الوسواس الخن
الناس
الذي يوسوس في صدور
من الجنه
والناس
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن
حمدا
اللهم اهدنا فيمن هديت وعافنا فيمن عافيت
وتولنا فيمن توليت
وبارك لنا فيما اعطيت
وقنا شر ما قضيت
فانك
تقضي ولا يقضى عليك
وانه لا يذل من واليت
ولا يعز من عاديت
تباركت
ربنا وتعاليت
لا ملجا ولا منجا منك الا اليك
لك الحمد على ما اعطيت
ولك الشكر على ما انعمت ت به واوليت
ربنا انت نور السماوات والارض ربنا لك
الحمد حتى ترضى ولك الحمد اذا رضيت
ولك الحمد بعد الرضا ولك الحمد على كل حال
لك الحمد انت نور السماوات والارض
لك الحمد انت قيوم السماوات والارض اللهم
صل على محمد وعلى ال محمد كما صليت على
ابراهيم وعلى ال ابراهيم
انك حميد مجيد
اللهم بارك على محمد
وعلى ال محمد كما باركت على ابراهيم
وعلى
ال ابراهيم
في العالمين
انك حميد مجيد
اللهم اننا عبدك بنو عبدك بنو
مائك نواصينا في يدك ماض فينا حكمك عدل
فيناؤك
نسالك بكل اسم هو لك سميت
به نفسك او انزلته
في كتابك او علمته احدا
من خلقك او استاثرت به في علم الغيب عندك
ان تجعل القران ربيع قلوبنا
ونور صدورنا
وجلاء
احزاننا
وذهاب همومنا
علمنا منه ما جهلنا
وذكرنا منه ما نسينا
وانفعنا
بما علمتنا منه اللهم اجعل القران ربيع
قلوبنا
وشافعا مشفعا فينا
يوم نلقاك
اللهم انس به قلوبنا
واسقل به افئدتنا
واسلل به سخا قائم قلوبنا
اللهم نور به ابصارنا
ونور به اسماعنا
اللهم نور به قلوبنا
واجعلنا هداه به مهدين
وجعلنا هداه مهدين
اللهم
اجعل قلوب نا وافيدتنا
اوعيه لوحيك اللهم اننا نسالك الجنه وما
قرب اليها من قول او عمل ونعوذ بك من
النار
ونعوذ بك من النار
يا عزيز يا غفار
ربنا اننا نعوذ بك من النار
وما قرب اليها من قول او عمل ربنا اتنا في
الدنيا حسنه وفي الاخره حسنه وقنا عذاب
النار
ربنا اننا شهدناه
شهدنا انه لا اله الا انت واتبعنا نبيك
فاكتبنا مع الشاهدين
والحقنا بالصالحين
اللهم اننا نسالك فعل الخيرات رات وترك
المنكرات
وحب المساكين
وان تغفر لنا وترحمنا وتتوب علينا
واذا اردت بعبادك فتنه فاقبضنا
اليك غير مفتونين
اللهم احينا ما كانت الحياه خيرا خيرا لنا
وتوفنا اذا كانت الوفاه خيرا لنا اللهم
اننا نسالك عزائم مغفرتك
اللهم اننا نرجوك موجبات رحمتك وعزائم
مغفرتك
والغنيمه من كل بر والسلامه من كل اثم
والفوز بالجنه
والنجاه من النار
اللهم اننا نعوذ بك من جهد البلاء
ودرك الشقاء
وسوء
القضاء
وشماته الاعداء
اللهم اننا نسالك عيش السعداء
ومنازل الشهداء
ومرافقه
الانبياء
والنصر
على الاعداء
يا سميع الدعاء
ذا المن والعطاء
اللهم تقبل منا صيامنا
وقيامنا
وركوعنا وسجودنا
اللهم تقبل منا تلاوه كتابك واعف عن خطئنا
فيه
اللهم اجعله شافعا مشفعا لنا اللهم يا حي
يا كريم
يا حيي يا كريم
يا
حيي يا كريم
يا من يستحيي من عباده اذا ما رفعوا اليك
اذا ما رفعوا اليك كفهم
ان تردها خائبه
صفرا ها نحن قد وقفنا في مقامنا هذا تالين
لكتابك
تائبين اليك رافعين اليك اكفنا
متبتلين
اليك
منقطعين
عن كل من سواك اليك
نرجوك ربنا
ونقسم عليك باسمائك
الحسنى وصفاتك العلى لما غفرت لنا ربنا
اغفر لنا ذنوبنا
ربنا اغفر لنا ذنوبنا
وكفر عنا سيئاتنا
وتوفنا مع الابرار
ربنا واتنا ما وعدتنا على رسلك ولا تخزنا
يوم القيامه
انك لا تخلف الميعاد
اللهم ها نشهدك وملائكتك
نشهدك ربنا اننا قد وقفنا في مقامنا هذا
نشهد بوحدانيتك
نشهد ان لا اله الا انت
وان محمدا عبدك ورسولك فاغفر لنا بهذه
الشهاده
واجعلنا من عتقائك
من النار
اللهم اعتق رقابنا ورقاب اباء ابئنا
ورقاب ابائنا
وامهاتنا
من النار
ربنا اجعلنا ممن لا يشكوا لهم ممن لا يشقى
لهم جليس
اللهم لا تدع لنا في جمعنا هذا ذنبا الا
غفرته ولا دينا الا قضيته ولا مرض
الا شفيته
ولا ولا مغموما مهموما الا نفست عليه
اللهم لا تدع لنا ذنبا الا غفرته ولا دينا
الا قضيته ولا هما الا فرجته
ولا مكروبا الا نفست عنه ولا مكروبا الا
نفست عنه اللهم ارحم والدينا
كما ربونا صغارا
اللهم انصر اخواننا المجاهدين المضطه في
غزه وفلسطين
وفي لبنان
وفي كشمير
وفي السودان
وحيث حلوا ربنا انصرهم على من عاداهم
اللهم اجعلهم على عدوهم ظاهرين
قاهرين
منصرين
عزيزين
غانمين
اللهم عليك بهذا الكيان الصهيون اللعين
فانه قد عاث في الارض فسادا
واستخف بدماء المظلومين المسلمين
اللهم انتقم لعبادك اللهم انتقم لعبادك
اللهم انتقم لعبادك اللهم نجعلك في نحورهم
ونعوذ بك من شرورهم
اللهم زلزل اركانهم
وصدع بنيانهم
واقتل اجنادهم
واقذف في قلوبهم الهلع والفزع والذله
والصغار والهوان
واجعل قتلاهم في النيران
واجعل قتلانا شهداء
في الجنان
سبحان ربك رب العزه عما عما يصفون
وسلام على المرسلين
والحمد لله رب العالمين
الله
اكبر
سبحانك
اللهم ربنا
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
سبحان الملك القدوس سبحان
الملك القدوس
سبحان
رمضان تراويح
جزاكم الله خيرا بارك الله فيكم
عيد مبارك عيد مبارك ان شاء
‏any other people love
جزاكم الله
السلام عليكم وعليكم
‏here
[Silence]
السلامك
الله
ما شاء الله
ابو بكر
[Silence]
‏I see
you look a complely
السلام عليكم
مساء الله خير
منا
السلام
ان شاء الله بارك الله فيك جميعا
بارك الله
في يوم عيد مبارك
عيد مبارك
[Arabic recitation]
احمد
اسكندريه
ص
[Silence]
بكي
কমেন্ট 160
[Silence]
اوكي
அலைக்கும் சபிஸ்
கடிபுல்ஹடி
[Silence]
م
‏Yes.
خ
[Silence]
‏These are mine.
Thank you, sir.
‏here this
did you get the
[Silence]
time
when the to
الله يرزاك
[Silence]
الله
بعض ان شاء الله ان شاء